how's it going everybody it's Warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about all things
Marvel and everything relating to the
MCU today we have a very interesting
rumor and very awesome rumor depending
on how you feel about it for Doctor
Strange in the multiverse of madness Sam
Raimi the director of the original
spider-man trilogy with Tobey Maguire is
coming on board to the MCU to direct
Doctor Strange in the multiverse of
madness and rumor has it that with him
coming on board to direct multiverse of
madness another person could be coming
with him and that person is reportedly
Tobey Maguire the one and only original
spider-man but when he comes his story
may not be exactly what you'd expect it
to be but don't worry I have the whole
story and we'll break it down right now
if you're new be sure to subscribe so
you can stay up to date on all MCU
content and so you can enter this week's
giveaway for a chance to win a
spider-man far from home Funko pop all
you got to do is subscribe but like the
video and comment down below I'm picking
a winner on Monday so this report
originally aired on the YouTube channel
the Lords of the long box and it's a
report from Mikey Sutton Mikey told me
about this over a month ago but of
course out of respect for him and Lords
of the long box I did not mention it
until now and the report reads as
follows with Sam Raimi now in the MCU
house of ideas for the next Doctor
Strange film rumors and speculation
abounds Maguire as spider-man
those whispers of suggestion are correct
there have been private talks but no
negotiations yet of Maguire returning as
spider-man whose trilogy Raimi had
directed real quick spoiler warning if
the following does happen it is
incredibly revealing about the plot of
Doctor Strange in the multiverse of
madness it's definitely something that
you have thought about but if you are
trying to avoid any and all spoilers you
should click away now discussions have
circulated between Sony and Disney about
a live-action spider-verse movie with
Tobey Maguire and Andrew Garfield
meeting the current Peter Parker Tom
Holland
however it's not exactly what you'd
expect what is currently being
envisioned as Sam Raimi's final goodbyes
to his spider-man an end game for that
world yes right now it's being talked
about that Tobey Maguire spider-man
could die in Sam Raimi's Doctor Strange
in the multiverse of madness and Sam
Raimi could possibly get a final goodbye
to
the character and that's the report so
apparently right now sam raimi is
planning on bringing his spider-man
Tobey Maguire into the Marvel Cinematic
Universe and Doctor Strange in the
multiverse of madness to say goodbye now
Sam Raimi has actually talked about this
before he's talked about the connection
between his original spider-man films
and Doctor Strange in the multiverse of
madness in spider-man 2 before the
Marvel Cinematic Universe existed before
all of these superhero movies were
connected he name-dropped Doctor Strange
Doctor Strange that's pretty good it's
taken wait wait I got it Doctor Octopus
and he's commented recently about how he
wish he would have known that he would
eventually go on to direct this film he
would have linked a lot more things
together but now he has the chance to do
that not only is he directing a Doctor
Strange film but he's directing a film
that is going to have to do with the
multiverse and that basically gives him
the power to bring any and all
characters if he so desired into the
film and keep in mind they've already
brought back J jonah Jameson the exact
same character that JK Simmons played in
Sam Raimi spider-man films they've
already done that for the current
spider-man films so it's definitely in
their wheelhouse and something that they
would do and Sam Raimi is looking for an
official goodbye to Tobey Maguire
spider-man the spider-man series that he
directed and now it looks like he's
going to get that chance and multiverse
of madness and not only that but bring
Andrew Garfield back as well and have
all three spider-man that we know right
now interact with each other I certainly
would love to see this happen I wouldn't
really like to see Tobey Maguire
spider-man die but if they need that
goodbye I hope they get it so let me
know what you think about this in the
comments down below would you like to
see this happen be sure to leave your
thoughts on the video like it and
subscribe so you can stay up to date on
all things relating to the MCU for live
updates you can follow me on Twitter and
as always thank you all so much for
watching
woof woof